I hit pan already I love makeup I hoard
makeup I collect makeup I'm one of the
weirdos that definitely is on every like
mailing list for every new makeup brand
for every new product that's coming out
I see makeup my heart skips a beat when
I Rea see make I was not a problem it's
not a thing look at this fresh makeup
hasn't been touched the mirror doesn't
have powder on it the seal still on the
mirror all the palettes aren't even
broken yet they're not shattered blue
Reds he's always making your teeth look
whiter do you want to know what we're
doing
hate this so much
look it's so perfect right now like look
at the tips not even use and it's just
oh it's broken off it's never coming
back
this is just like makes me so
uncomfortable this is supposed to give
someone some amazing brows
oh this is like what eighteen or twenty
three dollars this is like a week two
weeks three weeks oh this is like a
month now I just want to use it to cover
up something
look at it's perfect it's like nails on
chalkboard probably soft and silky I
know cuz that's a good formula
oh I've hit pan already I can repot it
I'm convinced I can repot this I've seen
the videos while you use is like alcohol
I just like use it first let me just
have one kiss
and I got one live in
well it's a solid formula it's not
breaking the beautiful tip is gone
okay this is such a great palette it's
red the red or Chur and can I just hand
my it it's such a good palette it's such
a soft formula you could just tell like
the color pigment is gonna be amazing
look how many smokey eyes I'm ruining
right now like what is like this color
so pretty
they're so soft they're so pigmented
yeah I'm so excited to use mine at home
now it has a better home it's gonna live
a better life
so this hurt never gonna do this again
don't try this at home treat your makeup
responsibly shout out to the beauty
community I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]